- I don't know how people
in India do the like,
I'm not going to do it but like the,
na-ah, that thing but I really like it.
When I think of Indian music
I think, Jai ho.
- A guy singing a scale
that's very foreign.
Aaaaaahhhh, right?
- Then there'd be sitar in the background
like nuah nuah.
(Indian music)
- This is when you get
like a ton of musicians
who are just like really
naturally talented.
- But it seemed like very inspirational
- And the rapper came in and she was great
and like it was kind of like rock n roll.
- That's so cool how they
can like come together
and make something that
can put Indian music
out there.
(Indian music)
- It's like a popular
song, it's like Jazz.
I think you can tell
that it's worshipful through the way that
she is moving that she's
devoting this to God.
- Like with the roughness
that there was in her
voice you wouldn't have
expected to be so flexible
and have so much control over her voice.
- I like listening to it but I can't say
I would choose to listen to it.
(Indian music)
- That chorus was like very catchy.
- I first heard it, I
thought it was some sort
of fusion with like Western
music that was highly
experimental but apparently
this is just what Indian music
is and that's really cool.
- Right when I think
of folk, I don't think
of like young people.
- Yeah.
- I would prefer to listen
to this than a lot of
crude music that I've heard so far.
(Indian music)
- When you think of India,
you think of like a song
like this.
- I like the way that like
they're singing really loudly
but it's not like oppressive to your ear.
- I just think it made me happy.
- I wouldn't compare it
to like a gospel choir
but like if there was
an Indian equivalent,
maybe that would be it.
- These are way different
from Bollywood songs.
- These feel like they have
like true emotion behind them.
- And it's very clear
having watched these videos,
that they're very
talented Indian musicians
out there that are doing incredible things
and collaborating in really cool ways
but that you might just not hear about.